there was a very special cameo in this
movie that he was in the movie but I
guess he's on like a big tour or
something it was a risk but I thought
risk too but he played the character he
plays like a farmhand and he did the
whole voice and everything I want to get
into a little bit of spoiler territory
you got to film a very special scene
with a very special cameo Oh with yes
all right
but everybody's been talking about and
yeah he was awesome people you saw how
people react to the Aesir they went
crazy when they saw him I know Stephen
King since chapter one after chapter one
he saw the movie and he really enjoyed
it and we started you know to have like
a very friendly relationship after that
so in this case I asked him to do a
cameo and his first instinct was was
yeah well you have to consider they had
high jinks my impression is terrible by
the way is that so all the movies where
I'm in kind of bombed oh that's what he
said yeah he said doesn't matter doesn't
matter Steve I think we can die we're
gonna fight this yeah we can fight break
the curse break the curse yeah he wrote
this character in the book of a
curmudgeon Lee Old Manor from Bangor
he's one of those guys that you know
when you go to your hometown whether you
can meet it big or no people feel that
need bring you back down here mm-hm and
let put you in your place it was like
that can a relationship and the observed
it's just so beautifully the he's no pet
or a person to play it then him because
he created it and just saw that like you
just need one scene you just know
exactly good that character doesn't it
does it still growing and if you get it
on the day and like half of his
brilliant like derogatory one-liner
zingers are just gone I was like what to
find myself in this situation but I'm
like I'm fighting with the right or
producer in the director to get Stephen
King's written words back into Stephen
King's mouth and I'm there I felt like I
was his agent or something like that
waiting for his right to respect the
source material you know I mean I don't
know why it was some weird mistake and
printing that half the scene just
disappeared but we fought for it and
they all go back and and he's brilliant
and nice
how did you decide what the the cameo
was going to be well there wasn't like
really a lot of opportunities for a
camera like that in the existing script
and a shopkeeper was great because he's
you know Stephen King like has like this
devotion for the description and he's so
detailed in his things and I remember
very much from reading the book the
whole episode with with the second hand
rose shopkeeper which is not exactly
what he plays and the we played more
like comedy it's more in the book is
more like a suspense weird like tension
between the guy who has a gun when he
sees build a brochure walking he puts
like his hand on a drawer and there's a
gun this is completely different
yeah so I thought it was a perfect fit
for him and he really dig it he did he
really enjoyed it and and it was a lot
there was improvisation the scene
maekawa came with a went with an idea
then Stephen King there was a lot of
spitballing there brainstorming and
there that made like the scene that you
see now more fun it ended up being like
that
you